der handschlag am ende dieser
pressekonferenz olaf scholz
bundeskanzler auf antrittsbesuch in
israel bei nachteile bennett dem
israelischen premier ein antrittsbesuch
unter besonderen vorzeichen in einer
welt lage und sie sehen die ukrainische
karte hinter mir die ganz besonders ist
und die ganz besondere fähigkeiten von
führung aber auch von diplomatie
erfordert darüber darf ich jetzt
sprechen mit meinem studio gast bei mir
ist klaus oelshausen generalleutnant a d
der bundeswehr aber gleichzeitig auch
ehemaliger deutscher vertreter im
militärausschuss der nato und auch bei
der europäischen union also eine lange
brüssel karte die sie ziehen können
mittlerweile tätig als
sicherheitsberater herzhausen wenn wir
mal bevor wir ukraine noch etwas
intensiver in den blick nehmen und
seinen facetten beginnen noch kurz bei
diesen besuch das war ein besuch nachdem
die angst zeit ein bisschen gestartet
ist olaf scholz hatte der
aussenministerin den vortritt gelassen
aber ein thema ist auch bei beiden
besuchen die wir dort wahrgenommen haben
in israel darauf gekommen was die
israelis sehr wichtig ist und das spielt
auch ein bisschen an auf das was wir
jetzt hier miteinander verhandeln
nämlich die frage des atom abkommens mit
dem iran und der möglichen
wiederbelebung
da sind die israelis sehr dezidiert auf
welche erwartungshaltung treffen sie bei
den deutschen
also die deutschen wie alle eu-vertreter
die daran mitwirken wollen natürlich
dass dieses räumte playoff action wie
der wirklichkeit wird dass sowohl die
iraner sich daran halten als auch die
andere gemeinschaft und so einige
amerikaner dorthin zurückkommen das ist
sehr schwierig gewesen nach der wahl des
präsidenten wohl der dass härtere
präsident sozusagen die wahl gewonnen
hatte da war er erst mal ruhe bis
november dann haben die rana auch gesagt
wir wollen darüber reden denn eins ist
klar dass die iraner seit 20 19 dann tun
ist natürlich ein klarer verstoß gegen
die vorschriften dieses planes und die
übrigen außerhalb amerikas sich dabei
waren mussten natürlich überlegen wie
lange wollen sie das geschehen lassen
denn mit jedem weiteren anreichern
kommen die iraner mit einer potenziellen
bomben er obwohl sie natürlich sagen wir
wohl nur friedlich diese atomenergie
nutzen und deshalb ist es jetzt zeit
kritisch alle wissen dass es zeit
kritisch ist denn irgendwann läuft die
zeit aus das muss zu einem verfahren in
der un compo zu sagen ihr müsst das
jetzt ein halten oder es gibt von allen
sanktionen und deshalb sind sowohl die
iraner unter einem gewissen druck aber
auch die amerikaner und die übrigen
teilnehmer wollen natürlich er jetzt ein
ergebnis haben auch wenn die zeit für
dieses ergebnis nur noch vier jahres
könnten die nerven irgendwann blank
liegen wenn es sozusagen ganz auf den
punkt kommt was der westen natürlich
angesichts jetzt der russland ukraine
krise und des krieges annimmt ist
natürlich dass iran im falle des falles
einer wiederannäherung auch durchaus ein
angemessener energielieferant sein
könnte das schwingt im hintergrund mit
und das bringt uns zum krieg zum angriff
russlands auf die ukraine heute tag 7
wenn man sich ein bisschen die köpfe
etwas näher anschaut und wir beginnen
jetzt mal bei der russischen seite
wladimir putin ist für fast niemanden
mehr richtig lesbar was ihn bewegt und
was ihn antreibt wo seine motivation ist
sie selber sind präsident der clausewitz
gesellschaft also sozusagen die
strategie und die kunst des krieges also
wo liegt die strategie von putin was ist
ihre erklärung ihrer lesart es gibt zwei
hauptwerke der verfolgt das eine ist die
großen die kleinen wissen dass sie in
die ukraine und die weißrussen wieder
zusammen zu kriegen das ist das erste
die sollen wieder in eine russische
föderation in welcher konfiguration auch
immer und das zweite ziel das hat er ja
noch deutlich zu erkennen gegeben ist
eine neue europäische
sicherheitsstruktur die osteuropa
beginnt aber sich nicht darauf
beschränken würde und das sind die ziele
in dem augenblick muss er sich
vielleicht mehr als er es wollte auf die
ukraine und den krieg konzentrieren denn
er hat sich sicher nicht vorgestellt
dass dieser teil einer strategie etwas
einfacher zu verwirklichen sein würde
also die beiden punkte hat er und da
wird er auch nicht locker lassen die
dienste berichten die geheimdienste
insbesondere das des westens das ist
alles viel länger dauert als das
offenbar geplant war klar ist dass das
ein vom timing her dass der zeitpunkt
die eigentliche entscheidung dies zu tun
wahrscheinlich schon im letzten frühjahr
gefallen ist so hatten sie mir auch
schon im vorgespräch berichtet wie viel
wie lange ist der atem den putin hat
angesichts dieser vorbereitung das ist
schwierig jetzt zu beurteilen weil ich
auch nicht beurteilen kann wieder rasch
für sanktionen die jetzt begonnen haben
auch die mittelzusage verringern die er
für diesen militärischen einsatz
verfügbar er hat sicherlich noch eine
reihe von militärischen elementen
streitkräften vielleicht sogar noch eine
dritte welle die eher dahin einbringen
kann aber er muss dann über seine
logistik über viele dinge neu nachdenken
wenn die wirkung der sanktionen eintritt
es gibt hinweise sie sagen also den
militärischen erfolg in der ukraine den
kanal erzielen mit allen folgen und und
verlusten auch für die eigene truppe
aber dann hängt er fest denn zu mir wird
es nicht reichen zumal er wohl auch
unterschätzt hat dass die amerikaner in
dieser lage in der lage sind die ganzen
europäischen staaten doch gemeinsam zu
vereinen eu nato und sogar bis in den
fernen osten staaten mitmachen igor
korotschenko war das der sprecher des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums
beide bei mir weiterhin im studio ist
generalleutnant a d klaus ohl zu hause
zunächst müsse bei den dolmetscher ein
kompliment machen dass er überhaupt in
der lage war in diesem tempo das alles
zuvor ziehen sie haben in ihrem leben
sehr viele militärische bildschirms
verfasst und statusberichte und auch mit
sicherheit vorgetragen was fehlt uns
hier
alles ist gut
das wichtigste für die russische
innenpolitik und alles was hier gesagt
worden ist richtet sich vor allem nach
innen denn er wird nicht glauben dass
das was er da sagt außen sozusagen auf
ungeteilte zustimmung stößt also geht's
nach und nach innen ist interessant dass
wir am anfang nicht aufgezählt hat was
sie alles zerstört haben sondern dass
eine reihe von ukrainischen truppen die
waffen niedergelegt hätten
der hinweis dass die soldaten die die
waffen niederlegen sozusagen nach hause
gehen dürfen und dann hat er etwas
gesagt was auch psychologisch für die
bevölkerung natürlich im inland in der
ukraine wichtige ist die versorgung der
bevölkerung alles was zu zeigen
organisiert werden muss nach unserem
sieg das haben wir alles im griff das
wird weiterlaufen da gibt es keine
probleme und dann hat er die
erfolgsmeldungen natürlich in allen
details angeschlossen und noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich zivile
objekte überhaupt nicht angegriffen
worden sind also das ist schon eine nach
innen gerichtete botschaft die zum teil
jedenfalls im ersten teil auch an die
ukrainische bevölkerung gerichtet ist
und das ist natürlich eine russische
wahrheiten es mehren sich auch wenn
nicht alle zahlen geprüft werden sollen
es mehren sich doch massiv die
augenzeugenberichte und berichte von
bürgermeister nitz weiterer das doch
sehr viele zivilisten ihr leben lassen
mussten bisher
herzhausen wenn wir ein bisschen schauen
da gibt es sozusagen seitdem die dienste
das genauer betrachten seit gestern da
ein bild das auch tatsächlich wirklich
wahrhaftig da war ein fotografierter
konvoi der glaube ich 64 kilometer lang
sein soll und auf die hauptstadt kiew zu
fährt normalerweise hätte der dann in
dieses bild rein gehört in dieser
russische wahrheit ja da ist da noch
nichts zerstört war hat er ihn nicht
erwähnt nämlich malen er hatte konnten
wir keine erfolgsmeldung machen es ist
überraschend dass dieser für jeden der
kolonnen in einen einsatzwagen ist es
sehr schwierig und 48 stunden sozusagen
im mini tempo wenn überhaupt in dieser
enge fahrzeuge stehen zu lassen das
können die russen eigentlich nur tun
weil sie in der gewissheit sind und dass
die luftüberlegenheit haben das ist also
keine luft zeigt kräfte gibt die diese
kolonne angreifen können und dass sie
auch vermuten dass es in den
landschaften rechts und links der straße
keine milizen gibt mit
panzerabwehrwaffen wenn beides könnte
diesen weg ohne erhebliche verluste und
verzögerung in ihrem ablauf beifügen
also michael hat das überrascht dass
dann 48 stunden ein minimaler
fortschritt dieser bewegung zu sehen
und nicht desto trotz die ukraine haben
genau das ja vom westen gefordert
abwehrwaffen und waffen um sozusagen
solche konvois aber auch andere dinge zu
stoppen bestimmte dinge hinzu gesagt
andere dinge sind auf dem weg manche
dinge sind noch ein bisschen in der
ferne da ist einiges noch im fluss reden
wir über den die widerstands-
möglichkeiten der ukraine die sind vor
allen dingen auch kommunikative natur es
gibt einen präsidenten der also
angetreten ist in seinem amt und als er
sich beworben hat und das amt
international auch ein wenig belächelt
wurde als leichtgewicht er kam aus dem
showbusiness er war ein komiker ein tv
unterhalter und er ist jetzt der held
seines volkes aber auch von vielen
anderen ja dass diese entwicklung war
abzusehen
an dem tag als er sehr deutlich
abgelehnt hat den vorschlag oder nichts
angebot vom präsident beiden außer
landes zu bringen und seither hat er
nicht nur selbst gleich mal statur
gewonnen sondern mit seinen worten auch
viele in seinem land erreicht ähnlich
wie auch der bürgermeister von kiew also
beide spielen aus meiner sicht gerade
für kiew für den entscheidenden punkt
eine wichtige rolle dass sie sozusagen
denjenigen immer noch wieder vertrauen
geben es lohnt sich sozusagen zu kämpfen
ja wir werden verluste haben er hat ja
an einer stelle mal gesagt ich bin das
erste ziel der russen und ich weiß nicht
ob ich morgen noch ein land habe das war
ja eine der frühen bemerkung gegenüber
dem österreichischen kanzler also er ist
sich dieser lage bewusst aber er
vergibt aussagen die immer auch wieder
vertrauen ist nicht der fall ist ist
klar in seiner kritischen beurteilung
auch in der frage das ist opfer viele
opfer gebracht werden müssen und erst
klagt natürlich auch an nicht nur die
russen in ihrer art wie sie krieg führen
sondern seine bitte
dass man ihn nicht alleine lässt der
richtet sich natürlich an den westen hat
das ja mehrfach betont hat dass die
ansprache über video hier beim
europäischen parlament gesagt hat ich
persönlich habe für mich den eindruck
gehabt eigentlich müssten wir alle
in schaan versinken nach dem was dort
gesagt hat und nach dem was wir nicht
leisten können nämlich den militärischen
das militärische einschreiten in kiew
und gleichzeitig hat er auch schon sie
haben das erwähnt auf dem sondergipfel
am abend sozusagen des einmarsches des
russischen einmarsches
auf dem sondergipfel der europäer den
den staatsmännern gesagt vielleicht
reden wir heute abend das letzte mal
miteinander
ich weiß nicht wie lange ich noch lebe
es gibt unbestätigte angaben darüber
dass bis zu 400 söldner in der
hauptstadt kiew unterwegs sein sollen um
ihn ausfindig zu machen und sein leben
zu beenden wenn sie ihn finden bestätigt
wie gesagt ist es nicht aber es gibt
mehrere quellen für diese angabe also
wurde die residenz gedanke für die
zweite runde war